And there we go. First clip of the
episode and that is the jet test done.
Doesn't look like any pet initially.
Going to go ahead and turn in the fire
cape. So, exchange. Take my cape man.
31. And not lucky. All right. Well,
there's 10 KC though. 50-minute kill.
Not terribly bad. Uh we're we're also I
guess I'll go ahead and get a task now.
But we're really close to getting uh 87
range and also 8k away from 88 slayers.
So hopefully we can get ourselves a cave
kraken task or an abbey demon task.
That'd be pretty cool. So let's see what
we can do. Oh my god. Could I kill
three, do you think? I think I might
give it a go. I have the range level.
Not not a great defense level, but we'll
try. I lied. I take that back. I thought
about it and I was like, I'm going to go
have to buy a armadillo crossbow and
just figure out my inventory setup. Not
worth it to me. Another task. Yes. Yes.
Yes. That's what we're here for. So, I
think I'm going to try to do sire. Now,
I think I do have to get the hasta
unlocked um to do this the best way
possible. So, I'm going to have to do a
few things to go ahead and get the
hasta, but some sire should be on the
way.
All right, doing a little bit of brutal
blacks just because I kind of want to
AFK, do homework and stuff. And ended up
getting 92 hit points. So, that's pretty
cool. Um I've been doing a decent
amount. I got 86 or 87 range here. I'm
12% of the way to 88. I don't know how
long I'll be here, but I mean it's
decent money and it's relatively chill.
So, not not terrible. This dude's just a
savage. [laughter] He's a fan of the
vids and said he was just going to die
for the video. I don't I didn't even
tell him I was going to record or
anything, but Jesus. All right, first
clip I've recorded in a while. I did not
decide to do the quests and whatnot
because I've realized that exams are
coming up and I don't have time to quest
or do sire. So, we're doing the abyssal
demon task here. I did get a superior
that got me up to 88 slayer. Also, 1550
total and got a dark totem top number
14. Kind of saving up for the skateo
boss thing, but also at the same time
kind of just chilling. I think I'm going
to go to the bank though here in a
second and go ahead and attach this last
totem top on. And then from there, I'll
go ahead and show you guys kind of what
I got from killing brutal blacks, which
is what I've been doing. All right, what
is going on, boys? So, here we are. Um,
[laughter]
we go ahead and get ourselves a jad
task. I'm not willing to do it, but if
you guys can't tell, this is postcom.
Um, I already uploaded this video once
and I was really embarrassed because I
was literally about to upload it and I
was like, let me check and see what the
sound is like. And I listened to like
the first second and I was like, it
seems it seems all right. I was like,
"Let's click farther into the video and
see if it gets any louder." And then I
clicked and I had like a minute where I
didn't [laughter] talk and I was like,
"You got to be kidding me." But yeah, so
I have to come back and do this now. But
I do end up just going on a huge slayer
grind if you guys can't tell. I love
Slayer to death. And with the school and
everything right now, it just really
works out to AFK Slayer and just get
that up as much as I can. So that's what
I've been up to a lot lately. And uh
yeah, this is kind of the big point of
the episode that we are nearing. And
this is I go ahead and skip my gargoyle
test because I wasn't feeling it. And
then boom, cracking. Oh my god, my
roommate's asleep. But what the [__]
just [laughter] happened? This is my
first cape Kraken task. Are you kidding
me? 50kc.
I've done like 1.5k in my main, bro. Oh
my god. I just I I
don't know. [laughter]
I have no clue, guys. This is
ridiculous. My pet luck on this account.
I have two pets on this account. I have
one on my main and I have like 2k zora
1.5 here. Like, [sighs]
I [laughter] have no clue, guys. I'm so
sorry for anyone that isn't getting good
pet luck because oh my god.
[sighs] That is sick. All right. I'm
interested to see what happens now. Ah
damn it. All right. So I think that Ne's
cave has Yeah, it's just been [laughter]
changed because I was in here when I got
this Kraken pet and now I'm in here and
this shit's just [__] Like [laughter]
what the hell? Well, I don't even know
what's in here anymore or where it is. I
guess I could look it up. But apparently
Kraken is now somewhere else, which
really doesn't matter to me. But now we
finally, my roommate's gone. It's the
morning. And I can kind of reflect over
this Kraken pet. Uh, it's just it's
crazy. And I know I probably I mean, I
said most of this last night, but it's
just I did not you never expect a Kraken
or any pet that early in the kill count.
like 50kc
and I pick up the pet again with this
and it happened last time. Um, the pet
kind of like moved out from under me and
I imagined that someone was just hopping
worlds under me and then I go and like
click it, but I like I clicked it in a
way that wasn't like I anticipated this
was mine. It was a way of like, huh? And
then I just Oh, I lost it, man. Two pets
already on this account. But yeah, so if
you guys saw my chat right there,
basically I've been trying to sell out
the mysterious emblems because I mean
they got to a point where I was losing
about 1.1k on them, which is perfectly
fine with me. I'll go ahead and take a
1.3 mil loss for something that could
have been like a 10 mil loss. So I'm
more than happy to sell them on for
that. Um it also, you know, opens up a
lot of money. But with that said, I have
no reason to kill Kraken anymore. Um, to
be honest, I I don't I don't need it.
Like, that's the only reason I would
ever kill Kraken. It's not good money. I
mean, it's not great. I'd rather spend
my time doing Slayer or something. So,
I'm going to go ahead and cancel it,
which is really weird. I never thought
I'd be doing this, but we'll go ahead
and get another assignment. And we go
ahead and get ourselves a Jad task. Uh,
yeah. I mean, I'll do it. Um, after my
math exam in like an hour and a half, I
won't have anything really to do. So, I
mean, I may as well, but I'm going to go
ahead and go ensure this thing now
because I am not about to die with my
pet. And back at Arty. So, there is one
thing that [laughter] I have to also go
ahead and do, which I'm not really proud
of. Um, I'm kind of an idiot when it
comes to just AFKing all the time, but
basically, I'm going to go ahead and
share this real quick. How can I help
you? You can ensure this [__] pet.
I'd like to insure for 500k. Sounds
aokay to me, buddy. Uh, the other thing
we have to do is go ahead and uh
[laughter] reclaim this. Uh, I think
that costs Wait, does that cost me a
million coins? I thought it did, but
you'd think that there's some sort of
dialogue box for that. Anyways, there we
go. Kraken and our and our Vetinatus
pet. Both are really low KC like, oh my
god. All right, middle of the fight
caves. I was streaming. I kind of got
distracted, but there we go. Went ahead
and got 88 range. So, a long ways from
89, but we're doing all right after. Oh
[__] never mind. I thought we were
close to a slayer level, but I forgot we
got one recently. And there we go.
Another Jad done. That is my 11th kill.
49 minutes. Not too bad. We'll get there
in due time, but we'll go ahead and
exchange the fire cape. So,
bargain. I know I won't get it back.
Give me the pet. Ah, okay. Well, maybe
next time. Here we go. Time to go ahead
and get another task. 178 trolls. I'm
streaming right now, so I'm trying to
keep the uh the content pretty lit. So,
we're going to say no to trolls since
that's I mean, it's an AFK task. It's
pretty chill. 167 dag. Should I I might
do DK since I'm on stream and a medium
casket. [sighs and gasps]
Man, why do I only get pages? Like, this
is legitimately a problem. As you guys
can see, I have Gothic pages. Um, if I
was an iron man, I guess I'd be pretty
happy because I just went four for four
and getting unique ones. But at the same
time, out of all the pages I have in my
bank, one of them is an armadil one, one
is a Saridomomen one, and now for our
Gothic, so kill me. All right. Well,
right now I'm trying to merge dragon
claws, but they're not really doing
anything. So, I'm running back to go
ahead and try to reflip them. They have
like a mill margin, so if we hit any of
them up, we are good to go. But we got a
cask in our inventory. Ranger boots. H
Yeah, that's that's nice. And get that
wood cutting level up. And here we go.
Another chest that I'm not getting
ranger boots in. However, a Bando's
miter. I mean, we'll take it for what it
is. I don't care anymore. I'm I'm just
done. Another medium clue.
Another adamant item. [laughter]
Casket number 78. Oh, okay. Strength
amulet tea. I mean, it looks [__]
sexy. Another clue scroll. And another
combo. So, that's the way that that
goes. But I did end up buying off one
set of dragon claws. I don't think it's
sold yet, but it's looking pretty good
to be honest. It's looking like an 800k
profit or so around there. So, we're
hoping we can do that. It honestly might
be a good investment considering it was
130 mil and like 24 hours ago and now
it's 120 like 1 mil. So, I mean maybe,
but I don't know. I think this is number
80. And uh yeah, still sucks just as bad
as number one. Another clue. And now
they're not ranger boots. Don't care
about the hat.
[sighs]
And another one. Okay. Okay. I mean, at
least it's trimmed this time. You know,
if I'm gonna get the adamant plate body,
may as well be a little swagged out.
Gonna go ahead open up another casket.
Got a Rangers call in the chat. And I
mean, a lot of green. A lot of green in
the clue scroll. Not the right kind of
green. That's not a weed reference. It's
a Ranger Boots reference.
[sighs]
Some more green [__] Last clue that
I'll be doing unless I get Ranger Boots.
Oh, [laughter]
damn. Maybe I should make that promise
more often. But we got an ancient page
too. A gold elegant blouse goes
perfectly fine with my female
complexion. I don't have any hair.
Anyways, not too bad. We'll take a 270k
loop. So, here we go. Going to go ahead
open another medium casket and all
adamant stuff. All right. Doing medium
clues and obviously always merging. So,
went ahead and made 1.45 mil. pretty
much 1.5 mil off a deite. But yeah,
really good merch. Forgot to record me
opening it, but really does it even
matter? I expect nothing. I received
nothing. Ah, I hate myself. I
accidentally put the wrong price on
these and I lost 2.2 mil. Kill me. Now
alls we can hope is I can just buy them
back for this price. God damn it. At
least now there is hope. There is hope
in the fact that now I know that they
sell for this price. People sell off
imbued hearts rather quickly. Maybe I
buy some back, but that was [laughter]
not the intended purpose. [__]
Meant to put them in for 38.
Uh I don't know. I meant to put them in
for like 38699
and instead I put 36699.
And uh it's bad. Really weird clue. I
had three straight Arty spots in a row.
Like I had to go to the zookeeper then
West Arty, then right down here. Really
convenient, but not ranger boots. Bang.
Okay. I mean, actually, that's worth
something, huh? Huh? Oh, inactive. Okay,
so probably not. Yep. [sighs and gasps]
911 oak planks. Too soon. What is this?
Like number 93 is my guess. Oh, nailed
it. Nailed it with a reward, too. 94.
[sighs]
Okay. Okay. I mean, we already have one,
but we can look [__] pimp. I don't
care. And number 95. I think we'll go
ahead and do 100 and then probably start
up on this DK's task. I have like 150ish
167. So, I'm probably going to split it
up between killing Prime and Rex because
I think you can do both of those pretty
easily. So, that's what we're going on.
I mean, I obviously have five more to
do, so we're not changing anytime soon.
But, that's the plan.
Just busting them out, you know? Can't I
I actually do hit this cash stack more
than like the last video. I was
surprised when I hit it. I was like,
"Whoa, is that rare?" And now I know
it's it's not at all. Like I hate it so
much. Boom. [sighs and gasps] More
adamant plates. I think like three more
god awful mediums and then I'm done. Oh,
thank god. Shazium and banner. Bro,
that's what I use to scam people. Like
no lie. At least a page maybe. Nope.
[laughter]
Could you imagine telling an Iron Man
that you're about to go 100 medium clues
without like a Zami page or I don't I
think I only have like three pages other
than Gothics. I have a full Gothics book
though. Oh yeah. I think this is the
hundth medium clue. So, oh, there we go.
We got the crier hat. I'm going to be
[__] decked out here soon. I guess
this is as decked out as you can get. I
guess they don't have legs, do they? Or
do they just No, they probably just
don't wear that. There's a lot of crotch
showing in that. I said I'd stop at 100.
I'm a dirty liar. I'm addicted. Oh, man.
That pays off for all my teleporting
that I do. Thank you. Another one.
Cool. All right. I swear. Last clue.
[sighs and gasps]
just can't give me anything, man. Can't
I should have ended on that page last
night. God damn it. All right, guys. I'm
streaming right now, but me and Fiery
Dragons decided to duo my uh slayer
task. Went ahead and got a B- ring on
kill number 24 at Rex. Um I have three
supreme kills and then like 20 prime
kills. So, I I definitely got lucky on
this, but that's really hype. I'm I'm
excited. So, we went ahead and finished
off that task. All we were able to get
was a berserkering. We also got a mud
battle staff which was like 90k. I went
ahead and split it with the dude. So we
made 1.6 mil on about the 60 kills that
we had there. And so it wasn't that bad.
I mean realistically in the future I'll
probably do it a little more, but
getting up the attack and the defense
would be really helpful and kind of
figuring it out a little more. But that
was a nice little way to get our toes in
the water. Onto another task though. 143
143 sukiquas.
Not a great task. I'm going to go ahead
and cancel it just because I'm on
stream. If I was off stream, it's good
XP, but it's not really exciting.
[laughter]
Trolls are worse. Not any more exciting
than the previous one. So, go ahead and
cancel that as well. 221 Dust Devils.
Uh, you already know I'm about to burst
these things. Well, got a medium casket
on that Dagonoth task. And obviously
didn't get anything.
[sighs]
Oh, okay. I mean, that's not bad. I
don't know. I like I like the way this
purple one looks. Obviously, I'm wearing
one, but we'll take it. Another casket.
Felt like I'd go ahead and do some
eclectics on stream and that was not the
right choice. Another test. 104.
Cool. Oh, 107. Jesus. And range of boots
and purple sweets is what I meant to
say. Another medium. Oh, okay. I mean,
we got a page. I don't care that it's
worth nothing. Still a page, so we'll
call it a win. Clue number 111.
And just as depressing as all the rest
of them.
Another casket. Another you combo.
Thanks a lot. Is it you? Oh yeah, it's
you. So I usually say ranger boots for
when I open these clues, but maybe it's
Amrock page or a war blessing. It's all
the same. All right. First clip that
I've done off stream for a little while.
So I went ahead and got a Dexterous
Prayer Scroll as you guys saw earlier.
101.3 sold off for 102.3. So, nice
little mill merch. Slowly, slowly but
surely trying to go ahead and make back
the money that I lost on the imbued
hearts that I hate myself for. So, there
we go. Got that done. Um, right now I
have a dust devil task as you guys
obviously know, but we'll figure that
out as time comes. Probably just going
to do a little bit of bursting, get that
mage level up. I think probably about
halfway to 92 or at least halfway from
where we are now. So, that's kind of
nice. Done with the dust devil's task.
So, I mean, got a decent amount of mage
off that. We're now 100k away from 92,
which is really good. Um, some people
said in the last video they wanted me to
go ahead and like price check stuff
after I got done with tasks. Um, some
tasks are a lot harder to do it than
others, but we ended up getting 330k
back. I mean, we spent a decent amount,
but I don't think we lost all that much,
but went ahead got another task. We got
sucquas. Not terrible. I mean, good XP.
They are cannonable, so pretty chill.
All right, here we go. This should be 98
strength, I believe. Yeah, 98 strength.
Combat 106. So, 1.2 mil away. [laughter]
Here we go. Time to get another task.
Finished off my sukquas. Not a bad task.
50 steel dragons. While I hate it. Well,
I was going to say I'm not going to I
was going to do it, but at the same
time, it's like ah, I don't want to do
that many steel dragons. So, 139 hell
hounds. We can AFK that. That's pretty
chill. Here soon, though. Here soon.
Once we start getting those tasks,
they'll be serverous, and that's
exciting. And time to get the last task
of the video. Uh, really bringing it
back. I think I am going to cancel Cave
Kraken from now on. I mean, there's no
point in me going there. I have the pet.
That's the only real reason I'd be
there. So, start off the next video with
Trolls. I'm going to go ahead go to the
GE. We'll find out the bank value. End
off this video on a high note. Let's do
it. All right. So, I have my worries
about um what kind of it's going to do.
So, basically now we have everything in
the bank that we can. Um I also have two
third age plate legs right here. So,
take into that take that into account.
Those are going to be 138 mil, I
believe. Yeah, 138 mil. Um, I can
actually sell them on for about 500 600k
above that, but we'll say 138 mil for
all intents of purposes. This is the
bank. Really unorganized. At some point
in the future, we'll sort that out. Look
at this. Like 76 rune full helms. I went
on a bit of a brutal black dragon grind
um during this episode that I'm sure you
guys didn't see much of, but that's
where a lot of those and these came
from. But yeah, so let's go ahead and
get on into it. So going to drag this
over hopefully. Hey, there it is. So all
right, so let's go on over to bank value
and calculate. And we're looking at
about 75. We'll say 76. We'll round up
because of these. So remember, we have
76 mil right there with those. And then
we go add 138. So that brings us up to,
I believe, 213 mil. So that is not bad
at all. Yeah. So, I I had to go and
check just to make sure. But yeah, about
213 214 mil. So, that's really good.
We're getting up there. We're getting up
there, boys. Um, this next episode.
RIP. This next episode hopefully we'll
get some stuff done. I do have exams, so
it may be a little while until it comes
out. Not like necessarily way too long,
but it'll be a little bit. And yeah,
this is the real thing that I am quite
happy to see this episode. So, hopefully
that was enjoyable for you guys. If you
guys liked it, make sure to leave a like
down below. Anything you guys want to
tell me, go ahead and comment about it.
If you guys really enjoy my content,
make sure to hit that sub button. Shows
me a little bit of support. Um,
Twitter's in the description. And uh,
yeah, with that said, hope you guys have
a wonderful day.